this is kind of a funny coda to the
Trump bleach injection Fiasco after
Trump wondered aloud about whether
disinfectants like isopropyl alcohol and
bleach could be injected or otherwise
introduced into the body to treat
coronavirus a whole bunch of Trumpets
denied that he said it the next day
Trump admitted to saying it but he
claimed it was sarcasm and then he took
no pressed questions at a press briefing
later that day and trumpets are now
dealing with conflicting defenses what
some are saying he never said it others
are saying it was sarcasm
and Trump admitted to saying it and says
it was sarcasm but it doesn't appear
Trump knows what sarcasm is maybe
shockingly longtime Fox News and Fox
Business anchor Neil Cavuto plain and
simple just admitted Trump wasn't joking
this wasn't sarcasm and it's extra funny
by the way to hear Neil Cavuto reading
the quote off of a transcript let's
let's indulge together marx yesterday
when he talked about injecting people
with disinfectant nor were we imagining
the incredulous loads he got from his
medical team when he made the suggestion
there was nothing in those comments
yesterday that hinted of the dismissal
he was giving today now he did waive it
aside that that was not what he intended
but that is what he said that injecting
people with disinfectant for coronavirus
showed some great promise he said I
think you said you're going to test that
too and it sounds interesting he went on
to say then I see the Dove that infect
disinfectant where it knocks it out in a
minute in one minute is there a way we
can do something like that by injection
inside or almost a cleaning because you
see it gets in the lungs here is
referring to the corona virus and it
does a tremendous number on the lungs
again referring to the corona virus he
said it would be interesting to check
that so that you're going to have to use
medical doctors with this but it it
sounds interesting to me he is talking
about injecting products like Lysol into
your body to see if that can combat the
disease that is what he said now he
might be dialing that
today I don't know why he just didn't
say look I screwed up I got it wrong
that wasn't my intention this is an
important medical distinction so much so
that the makers of lysyl came out and
said no no do not inject our product in
to your body notice how Neil Cavuto says
Trump should have just said hey I got it
wrong I was just wrong on this one where
is Neil Cavuto been for the last 20
years and especially the last three and
a half with Donald Trump as president
has Trump ever just showed up and said I
I misspoke I was wrong about XY and Z no
he took a sharpie and modified a weather
map when saying I was just wrong would
have been the right thing to do now one
other thing about Kabuto Kabuto actually
goes on to debunk Trump's claim that
only Chinese studies are saying
hydroxychloroquine might be bad for
people taking coronavirus here's Cavuto
saying this is data from our own FDA
that says it might be time to cut it
with the hydroxi secondly he goes on to
say on these findings they're still
unresolved on eyedrops of chlorine and
chloroquine it was the FDA not a study
in China that that said that kovat 19
outside of hospital settings or clinical
trials is is not to be combined with any
treatments of hydroxychloroquine or
chloroquine that that having an outside
of these venues there is a high risk of
heart rhythm problems I just want a very
clarify though these were not some
outside entities this was the FDA saying
whoa whoa outside of these settings
there are risk so this other study that
that it's got some worried that maybe
that the president was trying to dismiss
that has to do with the use of this to
treat to treat those with this condition
now the president has often said that
which drops of clerking these others
what have you got to lose well in a VA
study of a few hundred of our veterans
the risk is they have to lose their
lives Neil Cavuto has of course since
been fired by Fox News
I'm kidding but I do want to be careful
here because Cavuto has been a vector of
disinformation for decades on fox news
he's been on Fox News for 23 20 I think
since day one since 1996 so we don't
need to go out of our way to praise him
big picture the same way that just
because Trump is wildly more
cartoonishly sick than Bush was we don't
need to go out of our way to praise
george w bush but Cavuto spent a bunch
of Friday's show debunking Trump's lies
which is good because that's the
audience that needs to hear it most most
acutely the other angle is that we're
increasingly seeing Fox concern just
about the legal repercussions of how
they've portrayed coronavirus from day
one there's a study released last week
that suggests if you watch Sean Hannity
more than Tucker you were more likely to
get the virus which sort of tracks with
Hannity being much more flippant and
minimizing of the risk from coronavirus
so the stuff has a real impact if Neil
Cavuto really wanted to do the full
story
it would include mentioning that if
Trump was joking when he said inject
bleach that's one question but if he was
joking what is the joke like what's the
punchline they're watching this is a
very weird experience because the tone
of Neil Cavuto voice is almost like he's
surprised that Trump lied multiple times
during the press briefing Trump's been
lying during every single one of these
press briefings since day one good for
Neil Cavuto for calling out to lies that
it was sarcastic and that hydroxi is
working but still big picture Neil
Cavuto seems surprised that these press
briefings are nothing but opportunities
to disseminate lies and disinformation
we're going to have clips from all of
this on our Instagram page so make sure
you're following us on instagram at
david pakman show I also on my personal
Instagram will be posting a time-lapse
of my tomato plants rising like the
Phoenix to like about an inch sprout
anyway that's on my Instagram at David
Pakman